we're back hi everyone
Sean give them an appropriate intro come
on man don't call it a comeback hello
everybody welcome to the minimalist
podcast where we discuss what it means
to live a meaningful life with less
my name is Joshua fields Milburn and I'm
Ryan Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists Ryan how you feeling today
oh man I'm feeling I'm feeling all right
I'm like feeling like 90 95 percent I'm
just like you know this little cold I
had over the weekend that it's been a
long it's been a 2 2 week weekend
yeah man you've been you've been sick
for a while and now you know it's funny
I haven't been sick since we moved to
Montana and I've been sick twice this
year mmm I don't know what that maybe
it's like the the tour the stress of the
the documentary maybe you're sick of
this election maybe I'm sick of the
election which is appropriate because
today when this podcast is coming out is
Election Day
mmm November 8 2016 and we are talking
about focus and so there's all this
noise and and in sort of clutter
non-material clutter but nonetheless
it's clutter all around us and on stuff
all the time and so now we we're trying
to find ways to stay focused and aware
amongst that that noise hopefully we can
help with that today yeah so today is is
episode number 36 of the minimalist
podcast we've done 36 episodes already
really we really have we've actually
done more than that because as you know
and and much of the audience knows this
as well yeah we've we've recorded other
episodes whether it's on the road and
there's some duplicate content there or
sometimes we'll record an episode and we
just don't feel it and so we don't
publish it we don't we don't want to
waste anyone's time but welcome back to
the podcast we we are back after we've
been excited to be really back be really
excited to be back after this this long
break that we've had and we've been
publishing
past tour stop podcast you can go back
and listen to those but we are our back
our podcast is back and today we of
course are going to chat about focus and
our fourth you must focus like right now
our voice to voicemail our first voice
about question is from Jimmy in
Nashville
my question is how what chance do kids
have and what chance do we have without
the kind of education about not just
social media but also the media and how
advertisements are just bombarding us
left and right and what can schools do
to kind of make it different Jimmy
you're right we see about 5,000
advertisements a day that can even be
more than that if you're in a big city
with all these flashing billboards and
all this other stuff but we are
constantly bombarded by all of these
discrete bits of information whether
it's advertisements or just all the
noise that's going on around us or our
Twitter feed our Facebook feed and
Instagram and snapchat and and all of
these tools which which are exactly that
there are tools technology is what we
make of it basically and so when I look
at someone who is a teenager that or
just a little kid I know they're far
more impressionable and have these tools
have much more influence over them the
glowing screens have much more influence
I think of Ella my three-year-old who
anytime you place her in front of a
glowing screen she is is mesmerised and
I went about nine years without having a
TV at all and and now any time I find
myself at a at a bar or a place that has
a TV I'm thinking of James Barr I guess
I say let me go to bars why haven't you
invited me yeah I don't drink so I don't
go to those kinds of bars but I I
there's a restaurant here called James
bar and they had such a sports bar but
they have they have a million TVs yeah
and I have two I found especially if I'm
a farm with Becca or in a special phone
with back and L and I'm there
I have to position myself just right so
there's no glowing screen in sight
because otherwise it mesmerizes me and
so I think one of the things that we can
do is is try to reduce the number of
inputs so so be deliberate about the
types of inputs we have would take back
control of those five thousand
advertisements advertisements aren't
inherently bad
I think they inherently suck most of the
time it's the reason we don't do any
advertisements on our podcast it's just
jarring if I were to start talking about
hey you can sleep on this type of
mattress or have the sweat wicking
underwear or how would you like a nice
shave today and sign up for the
subscription service like we all hear
these things and sometimes those ads can
add value to our lives they can they can
educate us about something but most of
the time it's it is a distraction and
and I find that a Rob Bell friend of
ours uh who who has a great podcast
called the Rob cast Ryan he was recently
talking about there's a responsible way
to consume the news I am so so I found
that the thing that really struck a
chord with me I never thought about this
before but when newspapers first started
it was most likely in response to an
event that happened right so so for
example let's say World War one was
kicking all I know
newspapers obviously existed before
World War one but but just to use that
analogy you know the or maybe the 9/11
that that's a great example because it
is a distinct event that all of us felt
something about right we had this
collective cultural emotional tone that
was going on and so on 9/11 or nine
twelve when all the papers the front
page of the paper has to do with 9/11
well eventually you know whether it's
nine thirteen or nine fourteen nine
fifteen you're going to run a different
headline but it still gets the same
exact space you know could be that Kim
Kardashian gets robbed in Paris gets the
same coverage that 9/11 does because
it's front page above the flap and
kind of thing and so I tricks our mind
into thinking that all of these things
are equally relevant that Kim Kardashian
and 9/11 are equally relevant and I
don't think that there's some inherent
evil that newspapers are conspiring to
make us all believe that no they're a
business and they're trying to try to
get more eyes yeah they're trying to
aggregate more eyeballs and so we need
to take back control of that aggregation
by having by having fewer inputs it's
the reason I don't watch the news I very
rarely will well you know check out the
news feed because I realized a lot of
that is just clutter and it doesn't
necessarily got especially on the
internet so much we can click bait it's
yeah and it doesn't really influenced my
life unless unless I let it influence my
life right amen no I couldn't agree more
man setting boundaries has definitely
helped me to limit the intake of
advertisements in my life I remember
let's see before before minimalism came
along and I was a young corporate lad a
young bigwig um I got a man I had like
subscriptions to GQ what was the other
one
stock details yes wire acquire that's
what always it was Esquire Esquire and
GQ I don't think I details home garden
but but but I would constantly have like
CNN running in the background um I don't
know why like the metaphor though like
like news running and like there's
always this low level news that is low
level breaking news to which is even
worse
I mean break everything is breaking news
now yeah it's weird you literally they
used to like break into and that's what
I meant we're gonna break into this
program you you're watching Three's
Company or whatever and all of a sudden
the news comes on because we're you
don't watch reason I do I'll be waiting
for you you
remember that that's all they still love
this show so there's so much news and I
feel like we need to turn that TV we
have to be very deliberate with the news
that we take in yet turning the TV off
not having a TV I mean I've got a TV in
my house that I keep in the closet and I
will bring us all metaphor TVs in the
closet but ya know I bring it out when
we want to what like maybe I've download
downloaded a movie out of my computer or
Mariah's got like I don't know she's got
like a few DVDs that we've seen a
million times but if we're winding down
before bed or something you know she'll
put on her favorite movie 10 Things I
Hate About You
yeah it's actually based off the
Shakespeare play believe it or not but
anyway um but yeah I mean just limiting
ourselves and limiting the entertainment
when I first started realizing how much
noise I was allowing into my life like I
think the first thing I did is I went
and canceled like those magazine
subscriptions those were the worst for
me man because they were so subtle
because in a magazine like you have a
choice to look at the ad right like you
get a little piece of it but you
actually have a choice whether or not
you're gonna sit there and dig into the
ad and actually see what it says right
so you know for some reason I felt like
magazines were like probably the least
intrusive however when I started
thinking about where my desires were
coming from like I'm thinking of you
know this like Lexus f-series ISF is
what it was and and I remember like
having this just really really strong
desire to purchase this you know $70,000
car and didn't really even think about
where it came from but then I realized I
was like oh wait a minute that was from
that GQ magazine when I first saw that
ad and I sat there and like read the
whole thing and like totally ceded that
you know I'm gonna have to get this
$70,000 car so um not just cars but
clothes and watches and hey here's our
here's our top watch pick of the month
like I used to have so many watches man
it's ridiculous right so um but yeah
it's it's it was certainly the the worst
for me were the magazine so I cut those
out I eliminated you know my satellite
TV stop checking the news so much but
but certainly
setting boundaries is one of the best
ways I was going to say to you know be
the example Jimmy and you and your you
and your girl I mean if you guys want to
help with this this teaching you can
absolutely do that by just setting a
really good example I mean whether you
have kids or not kids pay attention
whether they're paying attention to the
parents whether they're paying attention
to their teachers whether they're paying
attention to their parents friends
whatever it may be kids are very very
good at picking up on subtle things so
what were we saying before the podcast
be be the change be the change that you
want to see in the world that's what it
was I think Shawn I think I think Shawn
came up with that on his own I think the
last thing that I'll talk about here
because you asked about this Jimmy you
said social media life versus real life
yeah and and and talked about sort of
authenticity the interesting thing about
authenticity it's the one thing that you
can't fake you because by definition if
you're being authentic you're not being
fake so you can't fake authenticity but
I think social media allows us to also
put our best foot forward if we're if
we're using it appropriately it doesn't
mean we don't want to air out all of our
dirty laundry but we do want to curate
curate social media but it's who we
follow and where do we get our our
inputs from and unfollowing things that
we don't find value in and quite often
we encourage people even on our Twitter
feed or Instagram wherever hey I don't
like what you posted okay I would
strongly encourage you to unfollow us if
you don't find value I you won't hurt my
feelings if you're no longer finding
value and what we're doing it's our
intention with everything that we do on
social media media to try to add value
to other people's lives and so I think
you can't
there isn't mock authenticity you can't
fake being authentic you're either being
authentic or you're not it reminds me of
an essay that we wrote a while ago I'm
going to read a quick excerpt from that
it's called please masturbate in your
own room there is a warning sign in the
dorm rooms at Miami University that says
and bold letters
please masturbate in your own room well
it's a fairly humor
warning and possibly a student prank
this line also seems to be a suitable
metaphor for our online world of course
it sounds vulgar but unfortunately the
analogy is apt many of us get so caught
up in displaying ourselves online that
we're willing to do just about anything
to get attention Hey look at me look at
what I'm doing pay attention to me as if
yelling loud enough will attract and
retain a large audience when shouting in
their empty room doesn't work people
often resort to silly stunts and obscene
actions the drunken Facebook pictures
the banal Twitter updates quote I'm
eating a pancake the shirt off in the
mirror Instagram photos the pop-up ads
and sleazy marketing which by the way
mate let me just take a step here that's
another thing that out of all the things
that drive me the most crazy billboards
tend to drive me pretty crazy
I hate billboards it's the reason that I
hate driving through South Dakota which
seems to be like the Billboard capital
of the world eat at wall drug a
five-cent I scream at wall drug I mean
and it gets you to because I could tell
you I've stopped at wall drug in South
Dakota before and but the thing that
drives me most crazy are these sleazy
pop-up ads I was doing a podcast
interview with someone recently and they
were like him I've got you know they
were talking about all this online
clutter and like I know that I'm part of
it I do you think I shouldn't have
pop-up ads on my site and I'm like I
think you answered your own question
there right like is this really
enhancing the experience of the person
who comes to your website to have a pop
up their hater email address for more
information right set up for our
newsletter have I ever went to a science
that I really wish they'd give me a pop
up so I could do something with that pop
up never I've never even considered it I
just know that I'm annoyed by it
especially I'm trying to read something
and all of a sudden there's this this
pop-up now it's not me telling anyone
that you can't do a pop-up ad I'm just
saying that I doesn't really add value
to an audience I don't think so I think
there's a better way to gain someone's
trust other than the the sleazy pop-up
ads and sleazy marketing the superfluous
cursing and blog posts all of which is
tantamount
to public masturbation people do these
things because it gives them instant
gratification someone might quote like a
picture of them inebriated and passed
out on the arm of a couch someone might
retweet their silly tweets someone might
comment on their obnoxious blog post
that modicum of attention albeit
negative attention can be addictive and
so they feel compelled to do more of the
same upping the gratuitousness threshold
each time the problem is that this
doesn't work not in the long term anyway
it never does sure yelling out loud will
attract scads of newcomers we can't help
but slow down and look at the wreckage
but we will never stick around to admire
the post accident cleanup
similarly someone's public and decency
might draw some initial attention but
they will be left feeling empty and
alone when the people leave the scene of
the accident and never return like
masturbating some activities are private
activities and they aren't meant for
public consumption be it online or in
the physical world this is one of the
reasons the two of us don't write about
our personal intimate relationships
online that stuff is private moreover it
wouldn't serve the greater good and
since our focus here is to contribute to
people and meaningful ways to show
people how to live a meaningful life we
needn't tell every personal detail of
our stories thus we show you our
personal lives up close and very
personal at times but we make an attempt
to leave out the stuff that does not add
value to your lives or serve the greater
good which means we hope we show you the
applicable parts the humorous parts the
aspects that have changed our lives in
hopes that those same things can change
yours we want to make a difference in
the lives of our readers to engage them
in thoughtful conversation and that is
why we write here not to show you our
private parts I will put a link to that
essay in the show notes to this episode
and Jimmy I would love to send you a
copy of our book essential essays which
is a collection of 150
says because there's there's there's
well chapters in there one of the
chapters is about technology and using
technology responsibly and way to send
you an e-book copy or audiobook version
of that we have a new audiobook version
by Justin Moloch which is now on iTunes
and audible and Amazon or if you want a
print version of that book what we'll
send that to you as well Jimmy we'll
send you one of those three Shawn will
reach out to you and get that taken care
of
our next voicemail is from Penney in
Cincinnati do you all find that
minimalism has helped you kind of pare
down your thoughts to really just get
down to minute meaningful things and
focus on the task at hand and if so what
you found to be the best ways to not
only just be um I guess mental in the
physical sense and really just find
value and things this that we see you
can touch but also in your minds and
thoughts and just thinking about thanks
living with a beautiful life that way
Ryan thoughts on thoughts my thoughts
suds um I have a lot of thoughts on
thoughts know meditation we've talked
about so much I mean if you are someone
who has a very busy mind meditate I
don't know if you're meditating now
penny but that would be like my first
recommendation is you know go get to 10
percent happier app go get the calm app
go get the whatever app that you choose
is going to be best for you what's
another one Josh let's round it up with
headspace app where you can go to the
minimalist calm slash Sam we did an
interview with Sam Harris and he has two
free guided meditations that get you
started yet I mean whatever it takes
whatever whatever it takes for you to
just start implementing that practice
into your life even if it's just five
minutes a day no it is not going to be
this like magic bullet answer but I
guarantee you that your mind will be
quieter and if it's not quiet around the
first day that's okay give it a week
it's going to take some time but
meditation certainly does help um you
know what did she ask it does minimalism
help eliminate the noise god I wish that
we could write an essay like become a
minimalist and your head will be quiet
for the rest of your life it just
doesn't work that way unfortunately
it's a it's a work in progress
minimalism for me yes it does help quiet
the noise but not in the sense of like
now I have just you know this clear
space in my head as much as I have been
able through the practices of minimalism
to eliminate a lot of the noise a lot of
the superfluous thoughts out of my mind
so I can focus on what is important I
guess the only thing I would add to is a
there is this in our documentary there's
a scene where Dan Harris is talking
about the the value of worry and about
going to you know you're going to catch
a flight and you have to be very aware
that there is a time crunch you have to
you have to be aware that yes there's a
time I have to be the airport I don't
want to be late and you know just a
matter when I leave for the airport I'm
always like worried I'm gonna be late in
the airports like 10 minutes away from
us like there's no highway to get on but
still like I will always stress about
like oh man I hope I make this plane you
know what if the lines long when I get
there but what Dan Harris talks about in
our documentary is there's a certain
level of worry that is helpful but then
there's this level of worry that really
becomes just this useless rumination so
a lot of the times when I have those
busy thoughts in my head I will ask
myself like are these busy thoughts are
they worth my time to focus on should I
you know write these down and think
about them or is this just a form of
useless rumination I know that has
helped me clear a lot of my superfluous
thoughts - yeah I think those three
words is it useful it becomes useful for
me because it makes me realize that many
of the thoughts these ruminations I have
that they aren't serving a purpose of my
life other than to clutter up my mind
and if you've ever tried to meditate you
realize how impossible it is to not
think about anything that's most people
who do mindfulness meditation will tell
you that's not the point of of
mindfulness meditation you're not going
to clear out the thoughts in your head
but you're not you know we're going to
be a slave to those - those thoughts
you're going to watch them pass and and
sort of float off into the ether and but
of course the next thought is always
going to come in the same thing that I
told Jimmy I would say here is
applicable try to have fewer
our inputs going on around you and that
might mean have scheduling alone time
whether that's to meditate or what Colin
our friend column will call 20 minutes
of awesome where you just spend 20
minutes laying there a letting your your
thoughts tumble and and sort of organize
themselves in a way or doing a more
formal mindfulness or meditation or or
maybe a TM meditation something like
that but on top of that I look at
clearing the the inside I start with the
outside actually I think our material
possessions are a physical manifestation
of what's going on inside us and so if
we have a cluttered exterior with all
this stuff strewn everywhere then we
often have a lot of stuff internal stuff
strewn everywhere inside and by dealing
with the superfluous clutter on the
outside we're able to start dealing with
this internal clutter this mental
clutter this emotional clothes going on
inside and so I think often a good first
step is making sure we've dealt with
with the material things in our life to
to an extent that we're able to look
inward and start to be be more aware
another thing you might want to try I
don't know if they have these in
Cincinnati yet but float tanks is a
great way to to turn down the volume by
turning up the volume and here's what I
mean by the first time I did a float
tank I got in there and it's sensory
deprivation right so you can just Google
float tanks and and in your city see if
you can find it but I it's sensory
deprivation it's completely black you're
in water that is 94 degrees same
temperature as your skin so you can't
feel anything
you're very buoyant because there's
1,500 pounds of epson salt so it's very
salty water and so you're just going to
float there it's it's pitch-black it's
soundless
there's just no senses you can't
simulate any sense and what happens when
you turn everything else in the outside
world down completely
man it turns up those thoughts I felt
like I was instantly cranked up the
volume on my mind and it allows you
through that hour that you're sitting
there to start to slowly turn the volume
down and you realize that you can regain
control of what's going on
side so it's a great way to to meditate
as well I would definitely try that out
just as an experiment I feel like I
still need to get good at floating cuz
like every time I float now like I don't
really turn it down till about like I
have 10 minutes less left left or like
five minutes left or something it takes
me forever but uh but yeah I'm only
throwing that caveat out there for
anyone who tries to float taking they're
like I couldn't get my mind to get quiet
at all the whole time don't feel bad
it's it's one of those things you have
to practice yeah and so my response to
that would be good
I'm glad you couldn't do it because you
now you get to really realize the
problem it's so freaking loud I didn't
realize how loud my mind was and how
unfocused I was until I removed all of
those external sort of pacifiers and I
think a big a big part of that is is
about being busy we're so busy now we
have all these inputs we're also we're
choosing to have all these inputs and
they're dictating how our life is and so
in our book essential there's an essay
that is called not busy focused and it's
one of my favorite things I just want to
read a quick excerpt from that as well
take a look around everyone is
multitasking we're doing more than we've
ever done attempting to fill every
interstitial zone with more work every
downtown scene is the same heads tilted
downward faces lost in glowing screens
technology turning people into zombies
we live in a busy world one in which our
value is often measured in productivity
efficiency work rate output yield
getting things done the rat race we're
inundated with meetings and spreadsheets
and status updates and rush hour traffic
and tweets and conference calls and
travel time and text messages and
reports and voicemails and multitasking
and all the trappings of a busy life go
go go
busy busy busy Americans are working
more hours than ever but we're actually
earning less money busy has become the
new norm if you're not busy especially
in today's workplace you're often
thought of as lazy unproductive
inefficient a waste of space for me busy
is a curse word
I grimace whenever someone accuses me of
being busy my facial features contort
and I rise and mock pain I respond to
this accusation the same way each time
I'm not busy I'm focused Henry David
Thoreau said it's not enough to be busy
the question is what are you busy about
and if I were to upend his quandary I'd
say it's not enough to be busy the
question is what are you focused on
there's a vast difference between being
busy and being focused
the former involves the typical tropes
of productivity anything to keep our
hands moving to keep going to keep the
conveyor belt in motion it is no
coincidence that we refer to mundane
tasks as quote busy work busy work works
well and for factories robots and
fascism but not so great for anyone
who's attempting to do something
worthwhile with their waking hours being
focused on on the other hand involves
attention awareness and intentionality
people sometimes mistake my focus time
for busyness because complete focus Apes
many of the surface characteristics as
busy namely the majority of my time is
occupied the difference then is that I
don't commit to a lot of things but the
tasks and people I commit to receive my
full attention being focused doesn't
allow me to get as much accomplished as
being busy thus the total number of
tasks I complete has gone down over the
years
although the significance of each
undertaking has gone up way up this year
I'll do only a few things but those
efforts will receive all of me this
might not look as good on a pie chart
next to everyone else who is telling
their productivity metrics but it
certainly feels better than being busy
just for the sake of being busy
sure sometimes I slip sometimes I fall
back into the busy trap that has
engulfed our culture when I do I make an
effort to notice my slip up and then I
course-correct until I'm once again
focused on only the worthwhile aspects
of life it's a constant battle but it's
one worth fighting
you know now we're gonna get a bunch of
tweets from robots claiming that they're
not fascists that's great not all robots
are fascists okay and so I really think
comes down to our most precious resource
here Ryan is is our attention right amen
what am i what am i giving my attention
to and that is what busyness is busyness
is letting someone else dictate how our
day goes whether that's getting these
incessant email streams or Facebook
stream or whatever it may be letting
someone else dictate your debt dictate
your day give you endless hours of of
busy and the way to to regain control is
to be focused on what you prioritize
what you want to focus on and so penny
I'd love to give you Ryan mentioned the
documentary I'd love to give you a copy
of the film so our film was called
minimalism a documentary about the
important things and either we'll give
you a digital copy with all there's six
hours of bonus content there online and
or we can give you a DVD the DVD is out
now as well so I'll have Sean reach out
to you then you know make sure that you
are able to see that because there's a
lot of the whole section on mindfulness
in there with Sam Harris and with Dan
Harris and some other folks as well our
next voicemail is from Brian wondering
if testifiers are ever okay or if if
something that you even identify as a
pacifier to begin with if you should
just eliminate it so my personal example
it's video games tonight I really enjoy
video game but I realized that there
there a time time hog or just way too
much time I'm spending on a video game
Ryan or pacifiers ever okay
yes next caller no I totally think
they're okay I mean anything in
moderation is fine um it's funny he
talked about video games I had to cut
video games out because I could not but
I cannot play video games in moderation
like the games that I play
typically like on Call of Duty there was
like this zombie mode that you could
play and like you team up with people
around the world and like I had friends
what like in quotes had friends like I
would play with and meet up with at you
know 9 o'clock at night and then we'd
start playing this one zombie mode game
and those games seriously I think the
longest I was ever in one game this
isn't like I was playing this long it
was one game it took seven hours for one
game it would limb from like 9 p.m.
until you know 4:00 in the morning or
something that was crazy and like when I
get done doing when I would get done
doing something like that it was a
miserable feeling it was like this you
know first off like so much stimulation
hitting my eyes and brain like it was
hard for me to even like lay my head
down at night because all I can hear
like zombies chasing me and you know
people trying to kill me and stuff but
but when I tried to limit myself to just
playing video games for maybe you know
an hour to a week or something it's
something that I just very very easily
would would lose control over I'm not
saying that video games are inherently
bad but they are bad for me because I
can't do them in moderation something I
have been able to cut back on like I
think alcohol is a huge pacifier for me
like it is a very very easy thing for me
to get caught up in social lubrication
kind of thing yeah exactly
or um you know you're having a stressful
day and it's just like an easy thing to
grab and be like oh I'm just gonna have
a couple drinks and ice I used to do
that a lot and now um you know I have I
have set limits around alcohol I don't
bring it into my house hardly hardly
ever up it was Mariah's birthday on
Tuesday and she had bought some bottles
of one that's the first time we brought
alcohol back to the house I can't even
tell you the last time we had alcohol in
our in our place um but but my point is
is that no pacifiers are not you know
this thing that everyone everyone should
cut out 100 percent of the pacifiers I
think we need to let loose I think we
need some distractions in our life but
yes a Brian if you're letting video
games dictate the majority of your time
and you are giving up more important
things in life
than video games then yeah I would
highly recommend you either yes limit
yourself to how much you can play and
try to maybe be a little bit more
moderate if you can't do that then yeah
man cut it out I don't think minimalism
is about deprivation but I found a lot
of value in temporarily depriving myself
of some stuff or from activities to see
whether or not I actually get value from
it when I when I got rid of my TV 9
years ago I realized that I hadn't III
didn't find as much value and as I
thought it was a pacifier for me I would
turn it on and it would just sort of be
on like the fireplace in the background
like what you're talking about earlier
with the CNN thing and I wasn't being
deliberate with the way I used it or
when I got rid of my my cell phone for
two months just as a test I brought it
back into my life
and use it more deliberately I don't
have facebook on my phone I don't have
email on my phone but I use it for phone
calls and I use it for yeah not as a
pacifier anymore but even even now if I
catch myself going
I will constantly move my apps around I
have an Instagram app on my phone I
constantly move it so that I can't
program myself to to instantly like pick
up the phone default go to it yeah but
it up quite often move my Kindle app
wherever my my Twitter or Instagram app
is so that I will instead of going to
those I'll instantly go to Kindle and so
really what I'm talking about here is
not just getting rid of the pacifier
that's one thing but but replacing the
pacifier with something else whether
it's getting rid of video games and now
replacing it with with something you
find more meaningful like books or
writing or snowboard it's some activity
that you you feel you're going to get
more value from than just the video
games maybe it's even just meditating
and I'm like Ryan said if you can do it
in moderation I found the best way for
me to do things in moderation is to
schedule them out in advance so I will I
will often schedule you look at my
calendar and it's like well I'm going to
watch television from 8 p.m. until 9
p.m. and then you know I know it's it's
like a new kind of appointment
television before the point of
television was like hey friends comes on
at I don't know I've never watched
friends but like I assume it came on one
night a week or something on HBO or
oh wait that's a different show hey
everyone threes company's coming on
Tuesday 7 o'clock and we like we don't
watch but now like you have you have
infinite choices with with television or
whatever and so instead of just sitting
down turning on seeing what's out there
pre pre schedule that time and that way
you have just a set amount of time and
you can look forward to it but once it's
over it's over and you move on to
whatever you're going I think it's a
great employment like using it as a
reward yes so like video games I mean
maybe maybe that's what you try to do
Brian like you know write down what are
the things that you are missing out on
when you play video games and do those
things and once those things are
complete then great you've got time to
play some video games and you can reward
yourself with it but yeah man don't let
it don't let it get in the way of your
priorities that is the that is the worst
thing that you can do yeah I would
really ask yourself do you find any real
meaning in those past 5 so you said you
have your you can easily identify your
pacifiers write those out and some of
them you may get meaning from and that
doesn't mean you can't temporarily
deprive yourself of it let it go for a
month or whatever and in fact that's
what I would probably try with the video
game thing because that seemed to be
your your biggest sticking point was
just let let go of the video games for a
month and see how that changed your life
but then figure out what you're going to
replace it with and if they don't truly
add add add value if they don't serve a
purpose or bring you joy then be willing
to let go of it altogether and replace
it with with something that you will get
something more out of for sure and and
you know I think we could all use
accountability partners or people to
help us through the process Ryan you've
got a whole team of of mentors would you
be willing to give him an hour session
with with one of your mentors absolutely
yeah actually Brian I'm going to give
you a free hour with a guy named Josh
Wagner he is an amazing writer he is
traveling the world right now
he's moving about every it's like every
90 days because of the passport and I
said yeah the visa the visa expiration
stuff
so my point is is that this gentleman is
someone who I really respect his work
and I know that he works really really
hard and I know that
has a lot of pacifiers that he could
absolutely run off with and distract him
from what is important to him but he
does a great job of maintaining a work
level and a good personal life you know
with keeping up good relationships so
forth and so on he would be a great
mentor to you to kind of help you
prioritize a little bit better and to
cut out some of those pacifiers what I
think is really cool about that so Ryan
you are a mentor and you take on like
five new mentoring clients a month but
but then you also have a team of mentors
who are really your mentors just refer
other people to four different things so
whether it's Carl who has run
multi-billion dollar businesses or Joshu
who's great with writing you have a
bunch of different people who who have
helped you with different aspects of
your life and you're able to refer them
off as well so if anyone else is
interested in mentoring it's just the
minimalists comm slash mentors and we
can put that in the show notes as well
so Brian I hope you find some value in
your mentoring session with Josh Wagner
our next voicemail is from Sarah in
Washington DC how do you maintain a
minimalist lifestyle I feel like I get
on I start with my minimalist mentality
and I clear everything out and I throw
away all the stuff that don't bring
value to me anymore
but somehow a few weeks later is it's
all piles back up again so do you have
any tips on trying to maintain
minimalism throughout your everyday
process and not accumulate so many
things again Sarah once said how do you
maintain a minimal lifestyle I think
it's it's kind of like going to the gym
you don't go to the gym one time work
out really really hard and say okay now
I'm fit for the rest of my life
minimalism is the same way you don't
like get rid of all your stuff and say
well all of a sudden now I'm a
minimalist and everything is fine no
it's it's more like another analogy I
would use is is a car if you have a car
you have to put gas in it you have to
change the oil and of course those
regularly scheduled maintenance and then
sometimes something just breaks a tire
blows al you have some sort of emergency
that have
and maintaining a minimalist lifestyle
are just life in general requires life
maintenance and so being willing to to
constantly reassess where you are and
and question the things that you have in
your life and the things you're bringing
into your life as well so it starts with
letting go of the stuff but then as
we're bringing new things in new
material possessions in we have to ask
is this going to is this going to add
value to my life but then that bleeds
over into all these other areas of life
as well whether it's your relationships
or your career does this align with my
values and what do I mean by that well
your values are just the person you want
to be in in some hypothetical future
right and so if are you striving to be
the best version of yourself those are
what your values are for Ryan and I
wrote about this in our first book
minimalism live a meaningful life where
we uncover our five higher-order values
health relationships passion growth
contribution and and I want to make sure
that I'm aligning my short-term actions
with those values so is what I'm doing
right now serving those values if and if
not I just have to correct it you're not
going to be perfect the analogy that the
guy who wrote essentialism Greg McEwan I
think his name is he talks about if
you're flying from New York to San
Francisco the plane is is off course 90%
of the time and it's just that other 10
percent of the time it's constantly
course-correcting to get get you back
towards your destination and so you're
going to get off course a lot Sarah and
I think what's important to realize is
the what gets you to where you want to
be isn't the fact that you're off course
it's the course correction and getting
yourself back on course and the best way
you're going to do that is by asking
more questions who's the person I want
to become does this add value to my life
what is my own definition of success and
then being willing to make changes based
on the answers you get to those
difficult questions yeah I would also
encourage you to I mean just take a look
at your habits um
the first thing that comes to mind
because I think first off there are so
many different ways that people can be
come you know get off course when it
comes to a minimalist lifestyle and you
just mentioned a lot of different ways
whether it's relationships or whether
it's health I mean there's a lot
of different things that people can vary
on Sarah specifically at the end of her
voice mother talked about papers so like
look at your look at your rules around
papers do you have any rules around the
papers that you hang on to that you
bring into your life like I'll tell you
my rule when it comes to like business
cards I refuse I will not have a
business card rolodex those days are
over for me I will not hold onto a
physical business card and for some
reason I like people always give me
business cards but sometimes it's
legitimate it's like okay I do want to
get a hold of this person later but that
doesn't mean that I have to hold on in
that business card and go file it in my
rolodex I will snap a picture of it and
then I toss the business card I throw it
away there are a bunch of apps for that
now too so you can also use technology
to help keep you more organized in that
respect yeah absolutely
so I mean take a look at the rules that
you have now I mean like I said youyou
were mentioning a that you have an issue
with wanting to hold onto a paper or
make a copy of a paper just in case you
know I bet you I bet you a million bucks
Sarah that you could eliminate 99.9
percent of the paper that you hold on to
if you if you got a scanner you could
scan them even like your tax documents
you can scan those like I don't have a
hard copy of my 2015 taxes like I have
an electronic copy of it my accountant
probably has a hard copy of it but I
mean even something as important as tax
paperwork that you should hold on to I
mean you got to have those records for
what six years is that what they say
seven years so I mean you got to have
that stuff but that doesn't mean that
you have to have a physical copy of it
so take a closer look at what your rules
are and adjust accordingly and you can
do a scanning party you can see the the
scanner that that Ryan and I used for
scanning a bunch of our old photos and
documents over at the minimalists comm
slash scanning that will help with a lot
of the the paper clutter and I think
Ryan's right I think you have to set up
some rules for yourself especially at
first because rules are just boundaries
basically right and so whether it's the
9090 rule have I used this in the last
90 days am I going to use this in the
next 90 days if not give yourself
permission to let go of it or maybe it's
the just-in-case rule I can replace this
item I'm holding on to just in case for
less than $20 unless the
20 minutes from wherever I am and that
rule has worked 100% of the time for for
Ryan and myself and we had to use it
only five times in the last six years
and so it means that it gives you
permission to let go of tens of
thousands of just in case items so that
occasion you might have to replace one
or two a year but but that gives you
permission to let go so really what
these rules do is they give you
permission to get this excess out of the
way which also gives you permission to
start focusing on that person that you
want to become if you want to see some
of the rules that Ryan and I wrote about
in our book everything that remains
Sarah I'm going to give you a copy of
that book it's on it's either a eBook or
a print book we also have a new
audiobook version coming soon there's an
old audiobook version out there right
now so we'll send you any of those that
you'd like Sarah hopefully you find
value in that chapter eight is a chapter
called clarity and it's some of the
rules that I set up as I was going
through this minimalist transition to
help me be more effective and more
focused on living a more meaningful life
our last voicemail question is from
Michael and Denver the question I got is
you know you guys have this blue
successful blog you have a top ten
podcast movie coming out you have a
share in a coffee shop and a publishing
company so my question is how you guys
stay grounded how do you keep things
simple in the face this kind of
burgeoning mini minimal Empire Josh how
do you stay grounded when we have such a
large Empire Michael I'm I'm really
insulted by this question you forgot
about our wildly successful books my
writing class that has helped thousands
of people learn how to write better you
forgot about our two TEDx talks which
have been seen by millions of people and
what else is he for all the speaking
gigs we often speak at University and
even talk about mentoring he didn't I
didn't you're forgetting about all of
these things that are really important
to us no I'm in all seriousness Michael
so so you're saying you guys have a blog
you have a podcast you have a
documentary you have a coffee shop in
st. Petersburg Florida called bandit
coffee you go on these large
scores sometimes you have a publishing
company you've written books writing
class whatever it may be and and the
question is well I think Ryan you were
saying earlier before recording it there
are two separate questions here right
like how do you maintain that but then
also how do you say stay grounded in
knowing that you're doing all of these
things and I think we can go back to
that that busy essay that I wrote from
earlier I'm not going to reread it to
you but realizing that these are the
things that were focused on and so I put
up a post on Instagram on our Instagram
account at the minimalists and it talked
about the last four years since Ryan and
I moved out to to Montana and I just
want to read a quick excerpt from that
you never know where you might end up
four years ago today less than two years
after starting our blog we moved from
our hometown Dayton Ohio
to a cabin on the side of a mountain in
rural Montana for four months to write
the first draft of our book everything
that remains it was so beautiful that we
ended up staying in Montana for a spell
much has happened these past four years
in 2013 we move from the cabin to the
big quote city Missoula Montana
population 67,000 to start a symmetrical
press a publishing house for the indie
at heart with our friend Colin Wright
and a gang of talented authors yes Sean
mihalick and Robin Devine and Josh
Wagner and chase Knight and others and
we worked on several international
speaking tours including our two
thousand fourteen hundred City eight
country excursion and we had some help
from our friend Sarah who hand a lot of
the the PR for that tour in 2015 we
focused on contribution we partnered
with a bunch of different nonprofits
including misfit Inc and the hope effect
and a handful of other charities to
build schools to build clean water wells
and orphanages across the globe and we
published an essay collection in 2015
called essential as well as
significantly updated a version of our
first book minimalism in early 2016 we
opened a coffee house which is called
bandit coffee
with our friends husband-and-wife duo
Joshua Weaver and Sara Weaver a few
months before the theatrical release of
our future of our feature-length
documentary minimalism which was
directed by our friend Matt dia Vella
and in parentheses there says hashtag
Italian stallion we produced that in
conjunction with our friends over at
spire media who often called the
Mozart's of web design they helped out
with a lot of our web projects as well
and we've done much much more including
a hundred free local meetup groups at
minimalist org which Michael forgot to
mention the free local meetup groups of
minimalist org and of course our podcast
which Michael did mention which is
produced by our friend podcast Sean Sean
Harding and music by Peter Doran so he
does our theme song for that and most
importantly we've both found partners
we've fallen in love whether it's it's
Becca or or Mariah and we we continue to
focus on our core values health
relationships creativity growth
contribution but of course it hasn't all
been ponies and rainbows along the way
we've experienced failure loss
frustration breakups heartbreak
arguments and many struggles along the
way however it's important to note that
while life is far from perfect we've
traded our old vapid problems problems
like consumerism debt corporatism and
discontent for newer better problems
letting go of the past to make a room
for what's on the horizon we never
planned on most of what has transpired
we never developed a business strategy
or a five-year plan or a vision like
that doing so would have overwhelmed us
and we likely wouldn't have accomplished
much of what we have accomplished
had we ruminated endlessly about
long-term goals instead we tend to focus
on one or two main projects a year and
this is really where I was trying to get
Ryan is is we focus and I went through
those projects there we focus on one or
two main projects a year keeping an eye
on the horizon not
worrying about what lies beyond it and
everything we do must serve those
endeavors if it doesn't then we say no
now for the sake of just saying no but
so we can say yes to that which is most
important as you can see from all the
names above as well as countless others
who have contributed to our projects or
share our message it has been a team
effort we certainly couldn't have done
it on our own nor would we want to the
minimalists are more than just a couple
guys from the Midwest it takes the
chemistry and creativity and shared
ideals of the whole group to create a
movement and so really I think that's
the takeaway for me is it seems like a
lot but when you break it down into its
little chunks it doesn't feel like a lot
at all in fact we tend to have down time
and I will force myself to intentionally
to not work because I I can very easily
fall into the workaholic status that I
had trained myself to be in the
corporate world working 80 hours a week
but I want to stay focused on one thing
year and everything we do whether it's a
podcast interview or going on TV show or
a tour it serves that thing that we're
trying to get out into the world and so
our podcast helps with that the
publishing company that we have helps us
publish our own book so we don't have to
wait for gatekeepers our documentary was
a new way to communicate with people my
writing class is a way for me to add
value to people's lives because I get so
many questions about writing and so
instead of constantly just answering
question have the same question again
and again I teach a writing class online
and so these are ways that allow me to
stay to stay focused without being busy
I still say no to the vast majority of
the things I want to do yeah and it's
funny too because like you could look at
you know this this minimalist Empire
that we have built I love how you use
that phrase it's hilarious I've never
really thought of it as an empire but uh
but you know you can look at all the
things that we do and very easily wonder
like wow how in the world do these did
these guys implement so many things and
I think it's important to discern that
we didn't do this all at once it's not
like when we started the website
back in 2010 you know we didn't have
like Josh said earlier we didn't have a
business plan of oh okay well first
we're gonna write books then once we
have sold enough books we're going to
introduce a writing class and then
mentoring and then once we have that
under our hat so we're going to come out
with a documentary that we're going to
do podcasts it didn't work that way
we we built on things slowly and you
know what we wouldn't have added
anything on our plate that we wouldn't
be able to take on and you know what
sometimes we've done that we did that
earlier this year you know kind of
mistakenly with the podcast where we had
to step away from it for a while and
that's the other thing too we're willing
to walk away from anything that we put
on our plate if it gets in the way of
the overall direction that the
minimalists are heading so we're council
asking each other that - how do I
simplify what can we let go of is there
anything that's in the way is there
debris here and Ryan and I meet quite
frequently and have these have these
discussions and so the other question he
asked was about being grounded right and
I think one of the ways that helps me be
grounded is a having Ryan here and
having surrounded myself with people I
trust so that I know that I get good
feedback as opposed to invalid vapid
criticism from Twitter eggs or whatever
I've learned that that surrounding
myself with people who are willing to
give me feedback and push back sometime
but also encourage when it's appropriate
I feel very supportive but by you and by
the other people in my life and it
doesn't mean that I surround myself with
yes men and yes women but it's the
opposite of that I surround myself with
people whose opinions I trust and know
they have my best interests in mind and
so staying grounded the other the other
thing that I do is I realized that I'm a
servant and the reason that we do all of
this stuff is to add value to other
people's lives money is never the
primary driver for doing whatever we do
sure we need to make a living and it's
great that we are able to diversify our
income these different ways because the
the interesting thing is I don't think
there's any one particular way that we
would make our living from doing this we
we sell some books or we have
we shop or or we do you know live
speaking gigs or whatever but we we
don't have one particular stream of
income that is like well here's the
thing that I'm going to live although no
we do a bunch of different things that
add value and if you add enough value to
the world you you tend to not have to
worry as much about money especially if
you've radically reduced your expenses
by becoming the minimalist
all right everybody we'd love to hear
what you have to say so if you have a
comment about focus including minimalism
tips for how you stay focused or avoid
busy work then leave us a voicemail at
four zero six two one nine seven eight
three nine where our favorite comments
and tips on the next episode we're also
looking for questions about gift-giving
and the holidays for future episodes so
feel free to call in with holiday
questions or gift-giving questions so we
can answer them for you okay let's move
on to our hashtag ask the minimalists
lightning round where we answer
questions from social media
indeed we are on twitter and instagram
at the minimalists and facebook.com
slash the minimalists and we're going to
try something a little bit different
with these lightning round questions
going forward starting today we're each
going to answer each of these questions
with one short shareable less than 140
character response so it'll be true
lightning around questions and we'll put
the text of those responses in the show
notes so you can copy and share our
pithy answers on social media if you
like all right our first question is
from clergy I'm very curious about your
social media routines how do you manage
to use your socials so well without
losing focus uh clergy I'll tell you
what I do I check social media once a
day that's it here's the question I ask
myself does this message serve the
greater good if not delete before
sending preach what's the next question
next question is from Lee focusing on
one task and doing it well as often
looked down on and multitasking is seen
as
superior where do you stand on this well
Lee there's a little bit of a problem
with your question because there is no
such thing as multitasking if I were to
add to that Ryan here's what I would say
there's only single tasking or single
tasking plus noise then next question
next question comes from Edie when you
set goals how far out do you set them
how often do you review your goals when
do you decide to change or kill a goal
and replace what is your filter oh my
god Edie first off your question
stresses me the heck out man second I
don't have goals if I don't need a goal
then I don't have it and what I would
say is instead of goals I prefer to have
a direction in which I travel if you're
searching for a sunrise head east for a
sunset west and that's just under 140
character so you can tweet that if you
want our next question comes from
Shelley I'm looking for tips on how to
keep focused when I'm trying to
declutter and still go about every day
life I'm gonna I'm going to give you two
recommendations Shelley first
if you don't meditate meditate five
minutes a day try it out second thing is
is take small steps don't try to do it
all at once for me I would say first
identify your ideal life then shed that
which does not serve your vision that
was much more Pythia than my answer all
right our last question comes from
natural grocers did we put a big natural
grocers tweeted at us yeah we're asking
us for advice we shop at their store so
maybe I don't know is this a sponsored
tweet I don't know is it's not a sponsor
of ours all right Ryan what is natural
grocers what what do they want to know
uh they asked us how do nutrition
choices affect focus in your life well
from what you liked yeah what do you
like to eat so no for me no for you
no for me no I'll just really really
simply put if I eat crap then I feel
like crap
what I'll say is eat real foods no sugar
nothing processed reduce carbs treat
food as nourishment not entertainment
okay now it's time for our added value
portion of the show this is where we
each get to recommend something that has
added value to our lives recently I'm
going to cheat a little bit here I just
did I've done a bunch of Ryan I both
have done a bunch of podcast interviews
because our documentary just came out
online in a bunch of different places so
we've got a bunch of media interviews
but also a bunch of podcast interviews
as well my favorite conversation I've
had so far was with a guy named rich
roll I really liked his podcast but I
felt like it was a really sincere
conversation almost a couple hours long
he met me at an Airbnb out in West
Hollywood and we just sat down and we
talked and man he brought his like home
studio equipment with them and we had a
really sincere conversation he got me to
talk about some stuff that I've never
really talked about an interview before
so if you want to check that out we'll
put a link to it in the show notes just
called the rich roll podcast I don't
know why but I really want to make a
joke about you mean this guy at an air
B&B in West Hollywood having a very
intimate moment
edit that out yes that was a great
interview man I totally agree that was
awesome
um I'm gonna recommend actually gonna
recommend what you recommended to me a
couple weeks ago wasn't that product
calm so--but what it is basically just
like magnesium right is yeah you have to
make sure you brush your teeth after
after taking it cuz it will it'll take
the enamel on the enamel off your yeah I
basically have been taking some like
melatonin to help myself sleep just
having some really weird sleep patterns
and Josh recommended this product called
calm that you just take a couple
teaspoons put it in a glass of warm
water before you go to bed and then
later you brush your teeth afterwards
which made the mistake of drinking it
before settles in no you warned me about
how bad the burps you get if yeah if you
don't like it's weird
I see they just expand your stomach and
you feel like you have this distended
belly or something but I've not made
that mistake yet but it's helped a lot
man like totally I don't know if it's
placebo even if it is placebo like I
will take it I don't think it is I mean
there's a lot of science behind
magnesium help it helping you sleep and
also l-tryptophan which I take something
called new mood occasionally my partner
Becca she does calm she has new mood she
does an eye mask and does uh these
really great your ear plugs called your
peace like peace as in peace man haha
yeah lover
um you know and it's not like this magic
like home is not this magic product
where like I don't take it and then like
instantly feel tired I think what it
helps me do is actually helps me stay
asleep because what I you because when I
was taking the melatonin like melatonin
does right away make me tired yeah but
then as soon as it would wear off at you
know 2 or 3 o'clock in the morning
that's about when I would get up is like
between 2:00 and 3:00 a.m. and now I'm
getting up naturally at about like 6 6
or 7 o'clock you want to cycle off of
melatonin I take melatonin occasionally
I'll probably take it I don't know maybe
six or seven times a month and but I
cycle off of it because you want your
body to be able to continue to produce
its own melatonin and so I I find that I
make sure that if I'm taking any of
these things I will cycle off of them
even if it's calm or whatever else so
that I don't become dependent on the
melatonin
yeah on the magnesium melatonin whatever
else I don't want to become completely
dependent because what happens if I
don't have it if I'm traveling I don't
have it with me I still want to be able
to to sleep effectively so yeah those
are our recommendation for today let's
move on to right here right now this is
where we get to talk about what's going
on in the lives of the minimalists I'll
start with a very personal note thank
you for everyone who has expressed
concern about my health I'll say a few
things one is I am feeling appreciably
better I've had three things going on
you can go back and listen to our away
episode I think it was episode number 30
where we took a break from the podcast
and the reason being is I'm really
staying focused on my health Ryan I
opened up my Delta app recently it's the
first time in over a year where it said
you have no flights
schedule I felt this full-body sigh I
was just like lay about calm that was
real calm for me it's not that I don't
want to travel in the future just like
we had been traveling so much here and
there and then we went on tour and we
were doing a bit more travel and it's
media stuff and and a lot of that took
its toll on me so I have three health
issues I'm working through right now so
I have my back issues I broke my back 22
years ago at age 13 I still have a
broken l5 vertebrae it's a hairline
fracture and I have a lot of nerve pain
well the good news is I've been doing
something called a gas Q therapy thanks
to some of our our readers earlier in
the year recommended that to me I've
also been doing some PRI yoga which a
friend of ours locally recommended so
I'm doing that a few times a week I'll
put a link to that the video and in the
show notes for this that means yoga sort
of in quotes
it's just movement practice and then I'm
also doing some regular physical therapy
every day I spend roughly 3 hours
sometimes 4 hours a day I've also been
doing the sauna four or five days a week
there's a lot of science hopefully I can
get this over to Shawn and time Rhonda
Patrick did a podcast on the benefits of
sauna use and she goes through all the
studies on on saunas and how it helps
stimulate your human growth hormone
which was helping me really repair my my
musculature I'm having issues with with
my continued issues with my back because
I'm also having issues with my gut
microbiome so that's the second issue
I've been having working with a whole
team a guy named Christopher Kelly and
dr. Tommy woods you can find them over
at nourish balance thrive calm they have
done a whole battery of tests with me
everything from stool samples to urine
to blood and saliva and doing all of
these different tests to understand
where I'm deficient and and learning a
lot more about my body composition also
my gut composition specifically and
what's going on there
I have something called c-diff which is
a really big deal it kills 14,000 people
a year in the United States and so
thankfully mine isn't as bad as many
people who
for horribly from it but I still have
significant issues with it now we are
working through those issues I'm going
through a lot of supplementation and and
prebiotics probiotics and a lot of
things this this team over at nourish
balance thrive and that this is not I
pay them every month this is not me
giving some sort of sponsorship to them
or anything I I literally pay them to
help me through these through these
health issues and they have been helping
me so far I've made some serious
improvements I still have a long way to
go and it's leading me to the third
thing I have something called MCS which
is multiple chemical sensitivities and I
know I mentioned that just very briefly
on another podcast and I got a slew of
people who have been asking and saying
ah sure a lot of their millions of
people were suffering with MCS so if I
walk somewhere I had to move recently
thankfully yo Ryan was able to take over
my lease of my old apartment we kind of
swapped and I it was a relatively new
place and even though it was a green
building I was very sensitive to the
sort of potpourri of new chemicals that
were in there paints and and floor
finishes and I find that when I go to
different places I am I'm allergic in
quotes to two different two different
aromas since that are going on I walked
into Best Buy a few months ago to get a
cable for something and I had to walk
out immediately it was just that
overpowering well now a lot of it has to
do it's all tied back to my gut
microbiome we think so my back isn't
healing as fast as it should be my
musculature is in my nerve pain because
I'm not producing my hormones are messed
up because of my gut so I'm not
producing enough growth hormone and
other hormones are out of whack which is
is is keeping me from healing as quickly
as I can
again I'm progressing slowly but then
it's also my cup is sort of full most of
us can handle our everyday chemicals
that are around us because we have an
immune system to deal with those things
but if my cup is full because my gut
biome is screwed up then any new
allergen or irritant rather any new
irritant is overflowing that cup and so
I experience that whenever there are
chemicals around and so I'm dealing with
that
best thing I found with the multiple
chemical sensitivities right now is to
just eliminate as many chemicals as I
can I use all natural products I know
one were using any any chemicals in my
house to clean anything or to wash my
body I I make sure that I'm doing the
sauna to get rid of all of these toxins
and washing off right away I do cold
showers right after the sauna which is
amazing for my mood too so I found that
there are ways to really to combat the
chemical sensitivity but it's really by
removing myself from the situation so I
can get better I think once I fix my gut
I don't know for sure but once I fix my
gut everything else will continue to
improve but thank you for all of your
your concern I am getting better and I
will continue to get better I'm very
focused on on improving my health now
Ryan you've been even traveling recently
yes
no we I got an offer to talk at this
event in Ireland Leitrim Ireland if
anyone know where that's at it's like
it's in Northern Ireland I'm not talking
about the country
Northern Ireland I'm talking about
Northern in the country of Irish yeah
the Republic of Ireland yes but it was
called cloud 9 this guy named breath
nearly put it on he won this race around
the world
was crazy he's nuts like he wrote his
whole bike around the entire globe was
freaking crazy and like under this race
and one um just a very inspiring guy and
I met him at a little conference called
misfits you guys might have heard us
talk about that before but essentially
he wrote me an email like hey man I love
free to come out speak at this
conference I'm putting on I'll pay for
your plane ticket I was like yeah I
would love to come out to Ireland
freaking love Ireland Ireland's awesome
but I didn't want to just you know stay
out there for just a few days I felt
like the last time we went on our our
tour and I got the chance to be in
Ireland into the UK it just like went by
way too quick and I really wanted to
have some time to kind of explore Europe
so Mariah and I I guess for the first
week of our month-long tour of Europe
was you know kind of working at this
conference it wasn't really worked out
because like it was just
it was just an awesome time I had to
give a talk and do the screening of the
documentary which you know which was
nothing but uh but yeah we went on from
Ireland to God where do we go we went to
we went to Paris to meet up with her
sister for a few days then we went to
Malta which I don't even hear I've never
even heard of Malta until I was googling
the island right yeah it's like just
south of Sicily you might see the name
Malta on a map but like the islands so
small like you'd have to zoom in on it
to see the island yeah um but I was just
googling where the warmest places to go
in September because like Mariah
like she's you know I guess where he's a
cold-blooded if she really likes hot
weather anyway she really likes hot
weather so I was like trying to find the
warmest place for us to go to and Malta
came up and like 1,000 Malta so I
started like researching it but come to
find out like Malta's is awesome place
like a ton of history um it's a
fortified city like they it everything
is like stone and it's just massive and
it's awesome and then on top of it they
have these ruins there that are anywhere
from like 3,500 to I think like 5,000 BC
so it was really cool to like go around
and see like some of these old I mean
they weren't really impressive you know
wasn't like Stonehenge or the pyramids
it was just more like you know these
villages that you know made made these
rooms out of big pieces of rock which is
really you know really cool but it was
just awesome to see to see history that
old and then from all those era
McDonald's that God did so many
McDonald's McDonald's is everyone this
one thing on our trip meant everywhere
we went we saw McDonald's really we
didn't eat there once oh yeah well I've
never been to like mainland Europe I've
just been the UK and Ireland yeah we
went to UM it's C from Malta we went to
Croatia Croatia is awesome and we went
to this place called a Zadar and it's
basically like it's like Florida a crime
he's just warm you know a little bit
humid ton of mosquitos there but
beautiful on the Mediterranean ocean
awesome people super affordable um we
stayed so there were five of us we met
up with some friends that I had met in
Missoula and they just had a you know
that happened
in Europe at the same time so we decided
to meet up in Croatia to kind of you
know make make something of it so there
were five of us we hung out for five
days
food rental car air B&B everything
together I think we spent like 60 bucks
a person
it was unbelievable like it was just
unbelievably affordable so yeah if
you're looking for like a cheap place to
go the ticket that are probably going to
cost you a little bit but if you get to
Croatia it's very very affordable to
kind of hang around the do we need a car
around for five days I think it cost is
like 60 bucks those nuts and then from
Malta we went to Venice and this was
pretty cool even from Croatia you went
to Venice what did I say Malta yeah yeah
from Croatia we went to Venice and that
was awesome it was it was a little
touristy for my taste we did not do the
gondola ride because it was like a
hundred euro to riding a boat on the
canals and it was just like you know I
just wasn't really our thing plus
markets seasick really easily yeah so we
didn't end up doing that but it was you
know it was cool for three or four days
to go there eat I don't even know how
many pieces of lasagna I had when I was
in Venice but it was really really good
but the most amazing part I think about
that whole travel it was just seeing the
different cultures and seeing how people
reacted to Americans I'll tell ya
everyone wants to know who you're voting
for and they and they don't posited our
who are you voting for they asked you
are you voting for Trump are you voting
for Trump like it's whatever us from
every foreigner asked me become a
reality TV show it's nuts man I can't
wait for the season finale of America so
ya know I'm glad I'm back
I'm glad we're uh what we're back at it
with the podcasts and I am I'm happy to
to not be on a holiday anymore it's
funny you're gonna be snowboarding
pretty soon right yeah it's the weather
it's cold enough yep yeah no definitely
man no it's funny how you take a month
vacation and it sounds really awesome
and it was really awesome but god man
like I'm so happy to be back yeah home
I'm so happy to like be back working on
stuff and and like I said doing the
podcast and yeah snowboarding is coming
up we were supposed to have an awesome
awesome snowy season
this winter but yeah I can't be down in
Florida for that I can't stinking wait
man oh my goodness it's going to be so
much fun well a couple other things that
are going on as as I alluded to earlier
our film minimalism a documentary about
the important things is now available on
iTunes Amazon Google Play Vimeo and even
on DVD you can watch the trailer and
find your preferred platform over at
minimalism film comm by the way if you
get the DVD make sure you pass it on to
someone else no need to hold on to it
afterward I hear a used version of
minimalism on DVD makes a great stocking
stuffer this holiday season but only if
it's a used version also on our most
recent book essential which came out
last year it's a 150 essays about 12
different topics it is now available as
a brand new updated six-hour six-hour
audio book read by our talented and
narrator Justin Moloch he runs a great
podcast called optimal living daily and
he reads some of our essays over there
sometimes but you can find the audiobook
and all six hours of that over on
audible or iTunes or on Amazon you can
even listen to a sample of the book on
any of those platforms also Ryan and I
are contributing again to something
called a simple year so a few years ago
Ryan and I contributed to this 12 month
simple living course it's called a
simple year it's hosted by our friend
Courtney Carver the founder of project
333 and man it was awesome and now after
taking a few years hiatus off of that so
we said no to it for a few years now we
figured out we could say yes to it once
again the minimus are once again
participating in a simple year along
with a stable of other simplicity
experts who specialized in areas such as
decluttering and travel and diet and
food and money and relationships and
work and you know what we would love to
see you there you can find the course
syllabus and read answers to frequently
asked questions and even become a simple
year member over at our website if you
go to the minimalists comm slash 12
that's the the number 12 all spelled out
twe l ve which is short for 12 months of
guided simplicity so the minimalists com
a slash 12 you can find the syllabus and
and all other details there registration
opened for that on October 11th so about
a month ago and it ends this week
November 13th is the last day you can
register for that if you're interested
of course I just want to put a caveat
out there Ryan and I will be the first
to tell you that you don't necessarily
need a special course or a book or a
blog to simplify your life but if you do
feel like you could use a little or a
lot of help clearing the excess from
your life then we hope you can find some
value in these 12 months of guided
simplicity oh and lastly we're getting
ready to publish a few holiday essays
and gift-giving essays in the coming
weeks at our website and we're also
going to post a photo tour of both of
our minimalist homes before the end of
the year so if you want to receive those
essays and photo tours then just sign up
for the free emails that we have over at
the minimalists comm it's the the box
there at the top there will never be a
pop-up ad but it's right there at the
top you just want to enter your email
address and of course all of our new
essays will be sent to your inbox
no spam ever because spam is yucky you
know I don't even think you could like
do a pop-up ironically and make it okay
which still Vietnam is out yeah yeah I
thought you know I I saw a pop-up
recently it drove me more crazy than the
rest because it said we know pop-ups are
annoying it was the first thing that it
said hey I know I'm being annoying but
I'm going to keep tapping you on the
nose good god yeah that that's Larry's
alright finally here are some voicemail
comments and tips from our listeners hi
my name is Lisa Benson and I'm calling
from wall fan mass I've been thinking a
lot about to veneers when you go on a
trip lately or recently our 10 year old
niece came up to visit us and she bought
something small for every family member
to show that she was thinking of them
when she was visiting and
traveling but I'm thinking of a
different way that you could show that
to a friend or family member without
having to buy them something which is
they give you something small to take
with you and give you to join or
treasure to object or whatever and you
take a picture of that that object at
some landmark or special place a moment
and you share that photo with them so
it's like a piece of them was with you
on the trip hi minimalists this is Jesse
calling from Oakland California and I
wanted to report on an instance of how
the lessons of gleaned from your podcast
have sort of brought me joy in an
unexpected way I had listened to one of
them about something where you set a
six-month a rule about she haven't used
something in six months either get rid
of it or if you think you might use it
again to get another six months and then
if you didn't get rid of it then to find
some way to get rid of it either sell it
or donated or just give it away but I
had excuse me I had an electric keyboard
that I was looking at selling and all I
saw were dollar signs of trying to break
even with it I wasn't using it
I was playing other instruments more and
I ended up selling it to a guy who had a
wife and kids was really good at piano
but I guess could never quite get the
money to buy one or one as nice as the
one I had and when he saw it on
Craigslist immediately jumped on it and
was really stoked on it when he came
over to check it out and I didn't
realize that getting rid of something I
wasn't using could help someone and he
eventually I think had a church gig or
something and so he was going over there
and not only did i declutter my live
space and mind but also help another
person as is going to put that item to
give use hello the minimalist first I
like to thank you for everything that
you do because of your podcast has
changed my life in many many ways and I
can count and I just want to say thank
you and in one of the ways it tells me
is I have the opportunity to move this
month but when I discovered you back in
the end of December of death exist
before your podcast started I decided I
would start to declutter my life and I
started with a closet of a car or
something small but every weekend I did
something and I donated car loads and
car loads to good world to friends and
recycled what I could and in that I
discovered that what really mattered was
my relationship was my happiness and I
discovered I was in a very unhappy
relationship and I addressed it and now
we need live apart and we're friends and
it's all for the better and I'm on my
journey to rediscovering myself what's
important to me my friendships my
relationships my hobbies my health and
I'm happier it's not an easy journey but
it's a happier journey and happiness
takes work and this lifestyle helps me
really focus on what's really important
and what matters and what matters has
always been us alright Joe welcome back
to podcasting that is it for this
episode if you all have a question for
the minimalists give us a call 406 two
one nine seven eight three nine
especially if you have gift-giving or
holiday questions those are coming up
real soon and if you leave here with
just one message we hope it's this love
people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without you
every little thing that you got a hand
every little thing that you guys you
gotta reach for and you got a grand oh I
bet that you'll be fine without me
so share your tea
you